what was some of your vibe in high
school I'd say I ran in like the uh the
popular crowd but I was friends with
everybody yeah a little bit funny yeah
you know I couldn't get buying looks or
if your uncle looks you go funny yeah oh
yeah trust me dude I feel you I'm like
an eight I've always been kind of like
an eight
and you gotta [__] you gotta and
eight you gotta come up with some jokes
yeah like on looks I think I'm out of a
ten yeah that's a [__] super high
score
I don't think you think it's that high
yeah eight eight so who's a ten
like what's Matthew McConaughey
I think he was a 10. I think he's coming
down a touch so obviously you knew that
you could kind of relate to everybody
then a little bit yeah that was because
sometimes as you get a little you start
to learn just some of your skills you're
like oh I kind of can fit in wherever
yeah I mean I was pretty good at that
did you have a lady in high school where
nobody no no no no uh
no I wasn't good looking I didn't really
do great with the girls at all in high
school what about like for dance is
there anything did you ask a lady out
ever like do you remember like the first
date you ever went on or anything like
that
the first date no I I don't I mean I
remember obviously going to like proms I
know who I went to proms with and [__]
like that but no I didn't really uh I I
had very little if any success in real
yeah yeah so yeah blue eye you're
handsome guy yeah I don't know no I well
first of all I went through it like
there's a whole fat day of stage not
that wasn't high school but I mean I and
I'm getting back to it because I'm
getting old but yeah no it's the truth I
tell you you always hear like you know
good looking people be like no I didn't
do anything like I was ugly and like
high school no I I was like I'm not like
those I don't believe the good people
like Jon Hamm like oh I I have it rough
my dick's too big you know like no that
I I really didn't do well in high school
yeah yeah I have to wear like an 80
gauge Underpants just to hold them up
yeah like that kind of [__] yeah I hate
that what about your first kiss in high
school what had to have happened huh
yeah I I'm trying to think who did I
kiss first uh I don't even know if I
remember it couldn't have been anything
what do you mean dude you are a document
tour of no I don't know it couldn't have
been that memorable
I I'm honestly trying to think I don't I
don't know if that's like sad or what
but I I honestly can't remember wow yeah
some people I remember locked us in this
room and they had this girl and she had
like a chipped tooth she had that kind
of that Lloyd Christmas on her you know
or at least the Christmas tell me your
first guess it was like were you playing
like spin the ball he locked in a room
or you just locked in the room like kind
of pervy older kids like you better get
in there and [__] kiss you know what
I'm saying we're gonna jerk off out here
and we're like Jesus Christ all right I
took a turn and so uh but she had that
Lloyd Christmas or at least she had the
Lord she had like that Lloyd Christmas
Eve it was like a less of a chip
but she had that thing and I remember
God she was also she was like the first
girl I ever remember really like seeing
with my eyes and she was
her name was Chrissy and she was
beautiful I thought and just bite the
teeth yeah so we had to sit next to each
other and just kiss what about the first
time you had sex you remember it that I
do yeah yeah now we're talking that
that's a little different than like a
kiss yeah yeah it wasn't great it's
still probably not [__] great you
know oh yeah dude yeah yeah when did it
happen College freshman
yeah boy
from his girlfriend yeah okay was it at
a party or was it like kind of a ah no
it was actually at so it it was at my
house it was actually summer going into
college okay yeah oh yeah dude I I love
like I love thinking about like those
kind of like just like times when when
we were young and stuff like yeah there
was nothing like that time getting ready
for college and then I almost feel like
that was the time you feel like you had
to like
you had to get sex active you were going
into college college and you don't
really know what you expect yeah no I
mean it was like a romantic thing did
y'all go to like yeah it knows romantic
it was definitely romantic she was my
girlfriend so it was a romantic that's
cool
[Laughter]
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one